- You look like a video girl.
(chuckles)
Woman.
- Mm.
- You look good.
- Marzel Dijonet,
our head of hair.
He just nailed that wig.
- Orange is a tricky
color, but I did
this hombre, kind
of creamsicle wig,
and I thought that
it came out okay.
I was like "all right".
And she can wear anything.
Any look you put on
Ilana, she embraces
it and embodies whatever it is.
So that's cool
- She's a little chameleon.
- She is a chameleon.
- That was really fun.
- You take it off.
- What would you want?
- More like, whoosh!
- Thanks for nothing!
(screaming)
- Everyday is like really funny.
The girls are always
in great spirit.
- Anyone that has an idea,
you know, funny wins!
- Yeah.
Whatever idea you
have, that's cool.
They're willing to
try it and go with it.
- It's cool that they're
not afraid to look weird.
Some jobs, it's
always about being
beautiful, or whatever, and
with this it's like you said.
Funny wins.
- Thank you very much.
- Ow!
- Those are dangerous.
- Oh, but they do come in handy.
My dear friend, Mae,
made these nails.
She's an incredible nail artist,
but this episode
is all about Ilana.
- Gettin' money. Makin' money,
and needing to play hard
'cause she works so hard.
- Which I relate to.
- So part of that
is expressed through
her nails, which
are dollar signs,
in dollar bill font themes.
And then Barack and Michelle
on the ring fingers.
Then the toes in the
tag, the fourth act,
which is also called the tag.
The big toes are
Sasha and Malia.
I hope the Obamas are honored.
- Yes.
I hope they are honored.